So describe your first trip.
So the reason why I came to be like Randy you have to find it a bit earlier this is in one thousand nine hundred ninety
nine we have a meeting in mom per year this is out of friends
and this is a meeting of people dealing with research on longevity
and they are very attentive to validation which means that if these old person are really so all tense all these are
demographic and so margin it isn't and medical doctor so at that meeting you know over ninety nine.
From Sardinia did a presentation
and in this presentation the Explain that in the neural province where we are either in the neural proteins the number
of made centenarian
and female centenarian is about the same we were really skeptical white because all over the world us five six even ten
times more female centenarian compared to maid centenarian So if you have a place where you have the same number it
means that probably the male as exaggerate their age so they declare that they are one hundred
but they are not one hundred so it was clear I remember the coffee break there
and during the coffee Reg They say we need to send somebody to validate to see what happens because it's a removed area
and the Montane there and the person from the Statistical Office of say probably that the data are not existing
or there would be problems and as I was probably the only one as historical demographic there I was volunteer
and so I say I would go there next January so we were in October
and I planned to come twenty of January two thousand and. Wonderful they collect me at the airport in Aguero.
They were there very happy that I will come
and they say we go to a celebration in a village of four centenarian in a village of three thousand a bit
and that was ours are not nearby and OK I say yes I am ready to go
but how can I congratulate this person if I will say just after that they are false OK So I say before to go to the
community I want to go to the municipal
or to see the document if if at least if they exist so we went quickly to the municipal
and they show me that there exist they show me even the birth records of these persons I say OK at least if even if I
am not convinced because they may be other error but at least they are document that they are no me to to check
and then I went to the city Beijing. Among the four.
Centenarian to go where they're in black and I have still in my office. The plate that they gave me.
Telling that on the twenty two of January two thousand I was there
and it sank me that's the really the starting point so.
The second step was that we have to go from village to village and to look people who read one hundred
and to check their document and that's what we did one by one and.
After two months I was able to conclude that I did not find any error. Only one small error was in this village.
A girl I see a girl who was supposed to die at one hundred
and ten in fact replace our older sister well this older sister diet at age two
and so there was a mistake because they considered that.
It was our sister and it was the second one so she was effectively one zero seven only one zero seven you see
but except this I did not find any error and were surprised about it and I was fully surprise
and that was the starting point of the second step because.
According to those who asked me to come on was perfect you have done your job all is OK
but then I say to my friend Johnny This is not the only thing there is something more strong more I will say more
exceptional Look I say
when you go from one village to the other every time you find new centenarian So they are not everywhere lost in the in
the country they are really group in the mountain area there is a nonrandom distribution of centenarians and I tried.
To do it to put on the map the village where we found centenarians and it was I did it slowly
and I put it in blue pen and I discussed with my friend I say you look this blue zone.
Already in March two thousand I was using the term blue zone to then to fight this area where they ever higher number
of centenarians when I mean what do you mean with.
Justice just because I use a blue pencil and with a blue pencil I marked on the map all the village and I.
Surrounded the place where they have this longevity and I
when I was discussing with my friend I say in the blue zone this outside of the blue zone this so the name Blue Zone
became family between us already in two thousand and
but the big difference is that in most of the study they are doing study on centenarian that are there they're there
they're.
Bit everywhere in the city here we are working with what I name population longevity which means the world population
is the even longer not only one or two person
and the other one are normal no in the village you may have easy two to three four centenarian
and even the Nigerian The number is incredible so.
I push the group to go to this new concept of population longevity
and then somebody in a meeting in October two thousand Tell me in the Roman
but I was it possible that these people reached in so large number one hundred or ninety
and that the men do it also very well on one side. But why you need this. But first the key point was that.
When I tried to explain it in the meeting that we have in Rome or with the same group.
They were really skeptical still skeptical and so I discuss with them
and I understand that the only way to prove that it is very unique is to take one village
and in one village to start to do the full in-depth story to work really
and then I say to my friend we will shoot the village that is the highest in the indicator the longevity indicator I
would say the one that is the sharing of the cake you see you have the cake is the longevity area
but you have one village on the top.
And that was the village where we had this girl one one of the ten ten that was effectively one zero seven
but I know that we are gone they may be a good place so we started in two thousand to collect all generals you get
and demographical data. Grandy but it took a lot of time. For a lot of reasons.
A reason first is that the work is not an easy task finally our database now seventeen thousand person with all the
family links
and a lot of things like that so it's you cannot do this in in one month's it takes you have to look all the birth
record of that record the on a graph of the population register
and so on so it's a very huge work so it took a long time
but in Sardinia there is not only the problem of data collection there is the problem of local sensibility
and after some times I understand that they what they were a bit disturbed by my work they considered that the local
researcher and moreover it was a local policymaker he was deputy in the region and.
I don't want any more that this foreigner because this is important if you are not from the I on you are automatically
for in that this for a no will continue to work with us he is disturbing me
and so at one moment my work was really the basis for a project in the U.S.
and I ate National News Digital Beijing we were directly rank it very high there was even a mention in in this science
that the magazine that this is the crack historical demographic that.
Validated this data so that was done in two thousand and then they decided because of this guy you have to grow.
I have a letter from my professor from the U.K. In the U.S.
Telling Michelle for the future of the research you have to go out from the system it's it's it's crazy for you
when you have such an abstract.
Just because you have a good idea and you feel you have to go ahead with this idea you know
but we are convinced that you are the one that is doing the work so I understand it
but that's not important for us I mean you are for us that one finds in our research in the blues so I would like to
continue on that and executive exactly tell me.
Looking at this this blue zone where we are here what in your opinion makes you so unique Why is this the blues
or what is it in these people that is so magical that they grow so. I think that.
I did not discover it at the beginning at the beginning my only attractive.
To me is that the number of centenarian was very high and that the number of male
and female was at the same level this is unique.
You will never find another place on hurt where the number of centenarian is equal between male
and female it was the situation in the past or it may be still the situation is simply so if she rang our India
but this is because of all the situation this is a question of local cultural situation
but in our modern society us more and more female centenarian compared to male
and so having a place where it's one to one while this is very few so.
Doing so I want
and moreover the indicator of the level of longevity for male was really twice more than in all of the country you have
a change out of ten to reach ninety and in good shape that's OK so.
We did it to sink we did first the data collection but we started also to meet people
and to try to understand why because. When you discover something.
You have to say what but there isn't a turret thing that we have to do is to convince our college
and it took me ten years.
To convince first that the data were true and that the situation is that there is this buttons between
and main if you need any they did even something that I never have in my scientific career they sent without informing
me.
Comment validate a new validation story another team to validate what I did
and that finally I get I got the information after and they found that it was correct
but it's so crazy to have such a situation that they need to really take ten years to agree with the situation part of
that that's clear So tell me about the second part of that what what next it's that this is the only place in the world
where there are male and female sentinels though when
when everybody agree on this then you have to start the explanation and. That therefore we started to do survey.
Not I would say it's not a survey with.
Very long questionnaire
and you know it's a survey that has a large part is open to question to try to understand this is one part of the story
then we also this site with the municipality to do a longevity celebration which means that to be very close with the
population this is the only way to try to understand
and progressively we point out the different aspects of their life that could could that might contribute.
Exceptional longevity the first one that emerge.
The fact that these people as a physical activity that really don't stop at sixty five they continue to work.
Even at ninety they decide to keep their garden and so on so there is physical activity that this really.
High level Moreover in the village of us seen if you go from one place to the other one you have always to jump the
slope every way which means that we are not in the flat area we are obliged to do effort on a daily basis.
In term of physical activity and physical effort that's clear there is.
A lesson that we have to consider from me it's not only a year it's always also in other places like this one around
the world so they live longer as active That's the point then. The second point is the fact that.
What they eat is quite different I will not say that that they do they have a method in the diet they don't have this
military and diet because for example somebody will say that take fish
but if you look the fish you have twenty eight kilometer from the sea
and in the past the fish never arrived here so it's not the fish it's meat they have meat
and they eat quite a lot of meat.
Their fruit and they have ventured the bill
but what is too important thing is that this is a locally produced food in the village they do pursuit also this
happens they do the collusion as this is a special dumpling they do the Sheesh they have the potato they have their
wine so I will say that compared to our western society ninety per cent of what they appear on the table is locally
produced and does not go throughout the food industry and for me.
I would say that in our country it's the oppose it you have ninety per cent that went out the food industry so the
natural food is very important but moreover.
I would say that the wine is not the best best best
and even they serve it cold if you have cold wind it for us it's a crime
but it's local it's not it doesn't go to our system where they add something they suppress you know that some wine now
you have a taste but the taste as been added
and so here you are sure that this is wind that they produce the tomato everything or leaf the same and so and so.
But as I say the meat become.
Quite abundant the pork at that for example
and this is the talk seems to be similar with other place to pork the goat not so much a cow so and
but what this clear is that these animals the meat of these animals is not the same as the one in our country because
these are the man has been in the mounting they at.
I would say a lot of herbs that are until York City and and that and so the meat is fully different
and that's something that you may compare yesterday I was in another place
and the meat was really want to feel fully fully different compared to what we have in our country where we go to
process that is not exactly so the quality of the food the locally produced food and then
when they do a meal it's not fast food it takes time OK they meet in the family so that social dimension of the meal is
also very important you may have two or three hours around a table a large family and.
And they eat they eat baby too much I don't know
but it's that the social dimension of the meal is very important sort of social infrastructure of the areas very
important exactly the social support for the oldest old which means for example it's the only place.
In the world that I have seen that they produce calendar with all the centenarian every year so you have a lot of thing
that happen
when we organize is the logic of it is a liberation that there were thirty one for the gravity of centenarian in the
street so they are really promoting
and centenarian promoting the longevity so that these very old people are not outside of the system you see they are
not push outside of the daily life they are proud of the daily life in this village the support to old people nobody go
there is no nursing if you have to go to nursing home you should go to to the city that is half an hour from you so
they stay in the village if they are not living with their child they stay in the neighboring house so they stay in
their own. Surrounding environment but they have direct support and if they have no children.
They are the neighbor people neighboring paper will take care of them down there is a solidarity there is a very
important so the place of the hold of all in the society is very very important
and I would say that our post modern society tried to put away after some age you are even put away at fifty from the
work you are away when you are becoming dependent they put you in a lurching all
and so you know you are really integrated when you were in the border of the blues or you have within the blues
and then just outside.
There is already a difference what is the difference what makes the just outside then and then I will say that.
This is the problem of the shaping of the blue zone which means that in fact you have a gradient
and grandees on the top the neighboring villages are not allowed now delay are not far from the top
and so you try to see what are the same.
Characteristic of these village but if you go to the valley there Dr Ali is there below then maybe the solidarity is.
The same but you feel a big difference you feel a big difference.
There are more people people are more the result of immigration
and why in this village people went out yes there are some immigration
but there are very limited people that arrive here which means that the problem is that the population is decreasing
because when you are young people you want to find a job.
This is not easy so one out of to leave the village at age twenty or thirty and the other one will stay
but then the population is decreasing so this village are really.
Keeping their cultural their specificity and that's why the solidarity is still the highest in the city like calorie
and and society this is not possible to see this there and that's very important point
but where does it stop this is the problem so we did it on the map.
A place that we named the blue zone with fourteen village by based on the longevity index
and then we have a larger one that cover all the Montane of Sardinia that is a light blue zone if you want
and then you have the rest of Sardinia and we did it based on a scientific investigation which mooting methods and.
But so we look for that the longevity index and now and now we go with this
and we try to see what is the difference between a longevity village and another one
and that's what we are doing now we are picking some villages that are not in the blues
and we try to compare what are the different between the two motors What are the differences how we are not yet far in
this because this is something not easy to do because we have different for example the level of dementia should be
compare the level of depression but also old genes genes
and the some biomedical indicator biomarker recently we discovered that there in the scene there is a big difference
between what what we found
and what we found in the city what differences are fine there is something that make I will say this is the job of my
colleagues never was what was what was what was that what it means that they are taking advantage of what they eat
and so on better than the one in the valley and it should contribute
but it's not easy to associate the two for example somebody try to explain that height you know people are very short
here they are an average one meter sixty four man and and they're you know even shorter
and somebody did find a gene explaining this
and now we are doing some review to see is it this genes is it something like that and so is the food and so on
but we so really big difference
and in the in the country the people in the mountain are shorter than people in the in the city where that that's very
important Can you imagine the average age at military service about one meter sixty and it's not so long time ago
and if you look in the village now you will see everybody is a bit short of that so that's that's one difference this
is a strong difference yes so you have probably.
Also some difference in the in the genes you have probably you have for sure difference in the lifestyle that's clear
in the city you cannot have the same life died idea of the quality of water air
and everything the absence of stress all those thing are really different the main problem for scientists is to put
everything in the same model and based on this just to conclude.
You are dealing with an interdisciplinary approach which means that you have an information from environment from
nutrition from other approaches from social issues from demographic from genetics
and even now from a pigeon It takes a pigeon it takes is a new way to enter in the study of longevity it's the
interaction between genetics and environment
and we are convince We tried to do something in Sardinia we generated we did not find any genes that may explain their
longevity in Sardinia but why because we need three thousand ten thousand centenarians to.
Do research we conclusion in genetics in a P.G.
Tips and that's very attractive with two hundred person you may already conclude something
and what is good is that usually they are now doing centenarian that centenarian plaque block like this here we will do
it.
On a population that this common trait which means the same food same environment so we are controlling a lot of very
able so that we will be able to see if something is really particularly
and we have already some explanation because the food is the same
and so so we are in the best condition to see if there is an A.P. Genetics of longevity and it is.
We already some explanation if it emerge
and wondering what what this explanation could be it should be linked to the special life of Shepherd So you have to
now that in the area.
Beginning of the twentieth century everybody was shepherds or as parents that were Shepherd
and so what was the life of a shepherd they have to go in winter in the valley six months
and they go really forty kilometer from here with all their animals only the men go down the shepherd
and they come back in May early May in the village with all the animals
and this is one week of big celebration in the village
but they stay only one week in the village that's why Nine months later you have a lot of baby justice
and then they go up to the mountain and they stay in the month in the world summer and come back in October November
and then again go to the winter so these shepherds spent most of their life outside of their family they have a very
different way of living they add very different food because they have to do to rely on their.
Own that they found and on this Brett that you can see this bread that you take with you
and may stay several months this be stuck with it this is bread that you have to wash before to eat to make it easier
to eat and so it's different nutrition different way of living and so I assume and the mother at all as all the.
I would say all the difficulty all the stress of the family this is the reason why men
and women live probably the same the same because their life is fully different but at the same time.
Having these very.
Positive aspect in the month in fresh air fresh water good food no stress
and so on may have an impact on your children and grandchildren
and it comes to be genetics because there is a transmission from generation to generation of some trade coming from you
may have this good genes but due to the vitamin it is not activated and that's very important or you may have a.
Bad genes
but also do due to the fact that it's not activated you will not be disturbed by this so rule of the environment is
very important
and this is a very good message for society because for me it would be crazy if I conclude with my study that there are
two kinds of people those who have this good genes and those who don't know that if there is a logic.
And somebody has the longevity genes don't problem you may do what you want you will live longer than the other one can
you imagine it is this is that at Mystic there is no solution
but know the good point with a passion it exists that you may activate on activate those you may do something yourself
and you may even take advantage of what your previous your parents and grandparents that
and maybe the secret is that a lot of these ancestor were shepherds
and has a wonderful life with wonderful situation with physical activity food and so on
and it may explain the difference between male and female and it may explain why the longevity is the highest
but that's it it really we are only at the starting point
and that's why it will probably go on several several years and when you look at when I would live here for example
when I would move into this village
and there I would start to know where I was discussing with colleagues it was in the meeting in Bosh. Don't.
They say this mission is a bit crazy because it seems to recommend to go
and live as Shepparton the bone pain know if you come here and live as shepherd. You don't have.
To work and it will take time to be integrated and to follow all the rules and so so I will not recover
and that every bit bigger will become arrive
and be shepherded will not change their life expectancy OK I mean provably the situation
but this is not the solution what we try to do when we try to do it now in the US to try to see what.
The lesson that you may take from this life here
and to try to transfer it in the other possible then society to see what this feasible what can we keep as lesson
and it's clear that the social links very important the food is very important the genes you cannot change anything
and this is not you not to concede physical activity is it's important not to stop to work suddenly at sixty five
and to say now I will stop working I was single only on my my wellbeing this is the only way to go directly to the
cemetery OK you have to keep active to keep your brain active but also physical activity and so on
and that's what we are try to do now in some places in the US in the so-called blue room project.
People in the valley in the city decide to meet
and to discuss between them so what can we do as a community to improve those things so the way to act is not to say
you have to eat this you F.
To do the tricycle activity and so we don't have direct interaction between our result
and in the video people we make the an environment so that they will spontaneously adopt or.
New and more appropriate lifestyle just to take an example in the restaurant we promote longevity food
or in some restaurant we give smaller plates because then you will eat you eat a bit less
and this is very good evidence that that will tell you that big caloric restriction is very good you have to eat until
your stomach is eighty person full but not one hundred so
and then you put in the shop for example you promote you don't promote the ships and the Coca-Cola
and so you put in the front.
Apple fruit and so on you are preparing a place to do psych that would do to bike to food you are
and grazing social links
and so these are all think that are in direct way to promote healthy aging so all what we are doing in here is to to
find what are the recipe for Healthy Aging
and to try to see which one can be transposed in other without coming in large number
and disturbing the world system because it's a nonsense you cannot hear you know better understand it
and some import also in this society I mean if there is some immigration I can believe that this whole village is like
a. Marker like a fortress does that what does that do to to the community and to the to longevity so.
In fact all our centenarian are born because they were born one hundred years ago
and the Immigration is only probably started after the fifty when the village was opened to the.
Electricity plant and so on the roads were better so I will say that nowadays.
Half of the marriage are married people from outside
but up to fifty it was ninety per cent of the marriage that were between two people from the same village we.
I mean that immigration the ear is really low
and it's very recent so we are not yet able to see the consequence of immigration but what I may tell you is that
when I'm talking in the village I try to convince them that they the longevity for them is a treasure.
But that it is really important to keep it from generation to generation
and I am a bit afraid that it might be a temporary phenomenon which means that
and I will explain it to you very simply.
The centenarian today work a lot in the past they have very difficult conditions so they are first elected
and then they have a very heavy life and very active life and suddenly in the sixty's when they started to to be sick
or to have a problem the public health was the globe
and they have suddenly access to a lot of thing against malaria for example in forty eight
and then they haven't lost people and so on so they take advantage of their past life what is very active
and modern life what bring them public health service and so on and so you have a conjunction of to sing
but in future the problem is that you will keep probably the access to public health
but you will lose the difficult life in the morning
and in the past it was your pose it you have only this active life
and no public health so for us there is a very important question mark is it a temporary effort that with the emergence
of a lot of longevity now and not a random longevity as it is in our country elsewhere
or is it something that we may keep alive for the future and that's accepting to discuss with local.
And to convince them that they have a treasure.
But they have to do a lot of effort to keep it
and I am a bit afraid that the young generation has not yet understood that this is a real challenge that's important.
And for you as a demographer Can you explain. What fascinates you. This part of democracy. OK this is another story.
I will say that. Some demographic the only thing that they are interested in is number.
Mortality table and so on they never met anybody they never bet the population with.
The danger act they don't know they just look in the starter sticks and work like this or they do more than once
or for me. I have always been interested to meet people. And to work at the local level my father was.
A mentoring teacher he was the master of one village he was the only teacher in the village at the elementary school it
was a village of three hundred inhabitants I know the village by heart I have been every way in the village I did a
story of the village the big book
and I have the full genealogy of the vision I was in the twenty already interested by the mana graphic aspect which
means everything on a given population so that you may try to understand how it works and when I arrive.
You have the initial request of validation I did it
but then this is what I have in in my interest this one a graphic aspect this this a contact with the population emerge
and I decide to go slowly in this direction to work on one village to try to understand not only demographic.
Also what is outside to meet people and to interact with this population
and now I was the one that introduced the longevity celebration I was the one that put this on the witness book Asprey
mother musky.
Mortality muscular they were very happy so they make me sit in the needle
or in this village so I am I am fully involved in the village I cannot walk in the village with without being in touch
with people so this is very important for me as researcher to be in close contact with the population where you are
working every day and to tell him them we do symposium in the village for people in the village
and we trekked researcher from all over the world from Japan Korea on Kong us and they come to Tokyo
and there was a translation in Italian
and people were there on the first row nine hundred ninety two trying to understand
but very proud that this is their village so you see this is a forty different way of working I am demographic Yes I am
basically demographic I am I am even astrophysicist at the beginning so I became demographic
but my main interest is not to be demographic is to do it to discover this concept of loser because for me it's crazy
and I see it every day how people are interested by this and to try to convince people scientists
but also other people this is a very exceptional situation
and there is really question beyond how is it possible that this iteration exists
and I'm still that I was retired four years ago and it did not change anything I am continuing
and I will continue as soon as long as I may do it
and convince young people to continue also because this is really an attractive story for you the magic word.
The magic work the measure of quirk. Patient.
If you are not question it with what you are doing in terms of research stay in your office try to publish a paper that
will not be read by anybody else
or just a limited number of person that are just happy together with your models though you know what we are doing is
really evil of interest for The Root population and everybody me
and the stand everybody be understand what we asked looking for
and as soon as we will got some answers we will come back to them and
and say look this is something this is something so this is really to be passionated by your research
and that there is no problem and you will go on you are you know are serious you are archetypes and we think of you.
Explore what you think rather.
Since I was very young I remember I was probably six I have already met on the wall in my sleeping room between I think
the first thing that interests me was your graphic variation so I I try all the time to travel
and I better try to travel than to read books I have a neighbor in my flat is reading books I am travelling I have a
brother he is in did not move one day he did not go out from Belgium when I have been everywhere so I want to travel
and not to travel as a tourist I want and this unfortunately of demographic
and on longevity bring me in so wonderful place two weeks ago I was in Caucasus in a valley I have been in China in a
remote place I have been everywhere in place where you are not tourist you enter in the family your try to understand
and why because you discover so wonderful thing and your eye both to try to compare the situation
and if you want to see something you need it.
Compare with other place
and that's what I'm doing to try to compare all those places around the world I visited eighty five different countries
and.
An older European country for example that you're traveling with what makes you an explorer a next priority as that
these travel are never planned by other people than me which means that
when I went to go causes three weeks ago I first start to look in the data I was everything
and then I say we have to go there.
Maybe in your rooms on me yes it was their wish was to see if well plays in Georgia maybe consider as blues
and to do this first I have to look to start the second data to work to look what is written and I have a.
Seventy three already somebody say there isn't caucuses and longevity so I went there already in two thousand
and three and I was really in trouble but then. Tallinn University say we will go to Georgia for.
Forefront of formation I don't know I say OK if you go to Georgia I go with you
but I have a really an objective I want to find the place that could be a blue zone and to go there
and to assess the situation so I started to convince them
and finally we went to the message of Ali this is just the a by the L.
Group the highest mounting it's a very remote area you need three hours to go to the village
and then three more hours to do forty two kilometer to go on the highest village of Europe two thousand and three
and it's a wonderful place I have never seen this place like this and then I will say that.
I organize everything and therefore you need to be in touch with local people because you cannot go
and visit the centenarian like this spontaneous the U.S. To do to.
To be in touch with local people
and finally what we did we have a guide that bring us during one day to visit six centenarian and.
It was crazy I will say because you have the possibility to enter a normal house one go to was told me I want to die so
you have really crazy situation in another one it was the Monday after Easter we were invited to the family meal to go
to the cemetery to eat on the on the grave there with them because this is the way they do it in a wonderful landscape
it was tertiary we've also invited to drink wine to drink the local and we visited six centenarian
and I remember this girl eighty seven no one no one no one running around me there and shaking
and then we did the survey the day after we went to archives local archives
and she was only eighty seven according to US So none of the six centenarian that we met was real centenarian How come.
There were their ID cards say that they were said that ARE YOU OK but if you look in the household book from thirty
and forty then you see that the date of birth is not the same.
This possible I have not yet the full explanation
but it could be possible that to get quickly access to their pension they push a bit
but in some time they push fourteen years you see it's a bit crazy
but as demographics we are able to see it quickly because you cannot ever a baby at fifty two you cannot marry for the
first time at thirty eight there is some aspect that you directly
and the stand so the survey just a survey asking did the Euro birth of children and brother
and sister bring us in trouble but the day after we went to the local archive the people were very impressed.
We found all the data and the conclusion was clear none of these centenarian was readers
and I so now I have to do a scientific paper because if you have a negative point you have also to tell it it's not
only see it in Sardinia it could be that I will conclude by a negative point oh probably it was positive
but the Coke has this I am sure there is no exceptional longevity why.
Two weeks before Corey and where there are two to do film and a lot of people go there they are very happy
but I have to conclude that it's not the exception where comes this wish of countries
or people who have made it now that having being.
So you have to understand that when it is the case yes
when a village is put into evidence for their longevity Everybody's proud of longevity Stalin was the one that promoted
the longevity in Georgia he was very proud of the longevity of the Georgian man and so if I have a village
and they want to be the first in longevity it's the situation here in Sardinia they compete between village to be
number one in longevity and if I come in read a grand day and say I will go to the next village
or are a bit afraid that I will found that the other villages better data than they have in store so it's really
competition
and I have even some problem because of this competition it's not just more competition it's a competition in turmoil
at policy level political level and so on and for a lot of think so they are proud of layered longevity
and everywhere and a country will be proud like Japanese to be number one for the life expectancy
and everywhere there's a Japanese wonderful Okinawa number one.
So you have to be number one and longevity seems to be the result of the best L.T.
Aging of the well being of the population longevity is something that is the best sign of this of well being and
when you say competition between villages here what I mean by that this is another story.
To joining ten year I promoted Grandy and I put it on the reader's book as the place where men are living longer so
and then I have some information that other village Arabic Jairus OK And I say myself that OK even a ground days on the
top the surrounding village are also not far so I expressed the wish to
and large the area of investigation showed there was one girl from that village there that was also interested to
attract people because she has a note I'll tell you there were some interest but she scientists she did a B a Ph D.
Does a bone so they start.
To bend it sure that different municipality will be interested but doing so they wanted to do and that's a C.H.
and Of Blues old village OK And I understand that they were at the end of the day they were Tree Association starting
their one with this girl one with with a professor in Calgary and one with vinegar
and they did do that also while Association
and then we had grand they say Michelle you are with us you have not to be with the other one so I was not able to be
with one with the other one
and we did third one then I my position now is very clear I am a scientist I want to be outside of this competition
and I want to stay at the scientific level too I will have today
or tomorrow some discussion with the sin that go with people to say I don't want to say that.
I am explosively with your village what is important for me is if one village is interested I may ask them to collect
the data what they do know five really just collected the data and I went there to validate
and they are also not so high but they are high in longevity
but just to give an example the village we will go tomorrow say Will.
Organize this celebration to give the diploma of longevity village and we give it to six village
and we are Gandhi was included but then during the dinner the saying that go ask me tell me I am engineer
and if you have indicator I know that you have the value of these indicated you may tell me what is the ranking to see
if I am really better than we are Grundy so I spend two hours to convience him that the topic is not the ranking the
topic is to say you are longevity village on the starter stickle viewpoint I tell him if you have a smaller population
there is a variation that is due to random So finally what I only can tell them is that you are both largely above the
Italian average or not and this is a statistical test and I hope Ike I was convincing
but I really understand that everybody wants to be the first
and now I have some problem with the other person that I did not answer to our last message because I don't want to
enter in a system of competition. And that's that's that's very crucial.